welcome to this video playing March our
bollocks metabolics ok so the this is
sometimes called the wait defense like I
get to this Bob wait WA de not wait and
then waiting so the fee and shadow is a
good line against that yes they often do
this it's an interesting interesting
approach the 95 oh no ok ok ok I see the
point if I go queen bee three i will add
will do that anyway with black can go
Queen d7 here because there's no Knight
coming to e5 yeah that's definitely true
should you 5 is 6
Bishop age three but the c6 it doesn't
really do much yeah maybe this one I
think he has to go e6 and now i can take
which is really debatable what what does
this if that accomplishes much and i'm
still going to do it and my ideas fy5
but he will probably play at five
himself this is what I only now got to
realize
I don't know I would we've expected f5
earlier maybe Bishop g7 looking at the
deep horn yeah okay he goes f5 anyway
let's just do it like that and put the
night on c5 that position is very static
so the night is a good piece maybe you
can play c5 now as the night is
unprotected 95 bishop jakes ok I
probably I get them I would have gotten
the porn up to see 60 not a big deal
yeah c5 he would get himself into her
somewhat we had pin so i don't believe
that one takes d5 bishop okay look see
one for that mentioned we had pin which
I really have a hard time to believe
that it should be any good for black
before is the immediate threat after
this
maybe it's called 85 maybe I can go
before immediately Bishop c5 before now
that is actually possible route takes
Knight takes five so he gives up the
exchange
okay yeah maybe just this just a ticket
there was what some before tricks
well that cannot be gonna be bad okay
black resigns hmm I think he definitely
was okay about here but him how I do it
to it somewhat differently so effing hi
folks you one yeah here c5 was the move
that i found interesting immediately
attacking here to eat eggs I'm getting
the porn up to c6 but i'm not sure about
the position not entirely sure something
like this trade of the active room yeah
I'd rather be white it's not not so
clear it's got the deep one as well
around here this is a bit it's a bit
uncomfortable yeah that just loses the
game yeah this is an important idea or
books you want the simple oopsie one he
doesn't really have a move here he
cannot move the Queen as it is tied to
the rook in 95 is threatened so really
no no move whatsoever
so I wonder if he could have avoided
could have avoided that I was thinking
something like Bishop g7 and maybe f5
but then also I'm not clear ok I've
Queen III just to be just to be annoying
and this and you can play how he can
check with the Queen maybe you know here
I think this looks a bit better than the
game but i can still rather YTN Oh looks
a little bit better but look better hmm
and maybe maybe white really keeps a
small advantage I'm better developed and
possibly have the slightly better
structure in different ego and c6 my
pawns are also not looking great but
they are not easily attacked hmm maybe
it is slightly better for what it's
nothing special but maybe just a little
bit ok well thanks for watching